now they let their legendary okay
they're letting down you're letting go
yeah alright they're letting them up
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you feel about that what do you
think nobody's watching nobody's
watching that's like an old-time Finnish
drug brother I've got Tyler was killing
my
[Music]
have a good day leaving basketball early
to go to your 7:00 p.m. 7:30 a.m.
business breakfast
like I just think you could sell you
have 50 60 70 cases extra every day and
this is time to do it this time people
need it the client and employee gift
[Music]
holiday
first of all most I just want to say how
much I appreciate all the comments there
the Instagram photos around the show I
just I just really appreciate the
feedbacks incredible
Omar saying watching at 5 a.m.
firefire I love that this guy right here
Brian bleep field saying love the fire I
love it too my man let's see let's see
what a fat Cox is saying here when I was
running our family hotel I would always
give all the dog owners a sausage at
breakfast not for them but their dog
they loved it I did it because I like
dogs not to try and get favorable
reviews however in return I had so many
nice comments and recommendations this
led to new customers
hashtag sausage karma comments are my
oxygen you know when you're putting out
so much content and you're playing the
long game and you're jabbing the only
thing that makes your jab sharp or more
importantly the only thing that allows
you to continue to jab is the comments
and so I'm very very grateful for all
the comments and the feedback and the
thoughts and the love that I get to the
Instagram photos on the askgaryvee show
pictures I put up for each episode thank
you thank you so much it really it does
help me to continue to help
[Music]
the parsonage
[Music]
[Music]
don't come in here you're not
[Music]
this means someone is writing this will
be recorded training purposes
more than half by more than
month-to-month knowing that's a big deal
the reason I was gonna work it's
religion yeah we've done the person had
started
a great car valuable content will always
win there's never a problem with the
volume of great content there's only a
problem of the volume of content people
people care about effort and and
actually giving a crap and providing
value Twitter video is incredible place
to do that and I'm stunned how many
people are not doing that for their
communities
yes Adam that's a private-label of wine
libraries Ian and I and Brandon really
worked on it and are in love with it and
I love the packaging Zach Bowen my my
designer at vaynermedia put that
together and just been a lot of fun
super excited about the project Madi M
I really appreciate it try a good
content is subjective and so the fact
that you think it's good and means a lot
to me thanks bro
John thanks so much for watching back in
a way well every two years the baby run
fix rediscovering me I appreciate it
respond say thank you for your attention
the only thing I don't like about the up
about the following me around
who looked harder from doing it from
yeah get out
[Music]
to see it likewise us no worries I'm
coolin Zack yeah he's our keynote
speaker keynote speaker Magister
yeah of course yeah okay mogul please
are pleased to buy shoes my man
understand
indie rock yep they're not letting us
upstairs because I don't have to choose
because of sneakers you get my teenager
okay so when you when you're done I just
ask you that I'll show you the way and
then you just come back jump out the
window
[Music]
their material
alright they're letting them up okay
type of it
computers are working with danger media
there's not a real person
in this industry Gary Vaynerchuk we are
excited to introduce you to Gary
Vaynerchuk CEO of vaynermedia people
this way by chopin's and if remember why
he is the NIP I show viens and no
backpacks hands full hands how many
people this we have sent an emoji week
attacks in the last month
[Music]
I would argue that the formal charge we
didn't even know what emoji was 24
months ago yet you just said what
they're a grown-ass man in here
[Music]
[Music]
pissed I get when people say that I'm a
change agent or a destructor I think I'm
the most practical [ __ ] person who
would be right back
yep it was it was the right amount of
f-bombs
[Music]
hey Kim how are you what why don't you
share it with her and tell her this is
your reality and that me you her
Alexandria Chris should all be involved
in the conversations around how do we
deal with this we run a business like
you don't go into Bergdorf's and say hey
Bernard this coat is eight hundred bucks
we're gonna give you 600 that's the best
part about being a business man there's
a lot more business men and women that
are kept trying they get seventy eighty
and ninety there is no 50 year old
athletes so like professionals so yeah
it's much better to be a business man
as a proxy to your psychology or your
things that are brewing for 2016 so
something worth debating
[Music]
I don't think anything is a good thing
or a bad thing I think you should spend
plenty of time with your girlfriend and
I think you should spend plenty of time
listening to my crap and getting better
but you should cut out it's all the
other stuff like deep bowl do you play
games on your phone
are you watching house of cards Breaking
Bad there's other things to cut pretty
sharp wanna get back
yay Silver 16:16 that's us
[Applause]
[Music]
they do they push it or do they just ask
why I love this weight-loss thing right
she came to us and she asked us to do
some research around with his team I've
learned something new about Facebook
once a week it's and I spend all my day
that's intimidating yeah and it's not as
if we'd say Gary fires something away
like to understand this machine it's
literally 20 minutes of Gary's time in a
room for the show yeah you never sound
like that that's actually a question so
we'll make that happen oh I got a real
curveball for you what okay how long
until you working here a month a month
working in to hit was being here I
walked out of my office and I said let's
go film this show the askgaryvee shows
first episode happen at random like
we've found questions right there in the
room
on the phone oh I didn't know that you
actually you know what it might you know
what for the two-year anniversary should
really maybe make a move like we should
maybe do what we're doing right now as a
story pal it even happened anyway is
that the camera used for the for them
yeah really I was ready to give him a
thousand bucks was a thousand dollar
question I'm gonna give you the money
should I believe ya you shooting now I'm
just going to goddamn camera
[Music]
if the daylight middle seat I like to
see no tell them I tell them why would I
do that if we don't have something
that's meaningful that's stupid
and they need to do it like what do they
do you reply to them CC me and set and
say Gary just
ballistically said no why when the
moderator is the ROI of the rationale
otherwise who gives a rat's [ __ ] ass
you're you're you're in the dead horse
business you have to be dead horse
that's how you wrangle me I'm not you
never have to add yet again
[Music]
yeah guys tent no matter how much in hey
what's going on to the $250,000 in books
and it will be on the back of a player
and you if you want to sell to
millennial moms like TV stinks because
you have to go vanilla and Facebook
doesn't because I can put Korean women
in it and Korean women target it and
they'll convert matter that is uniquely
you uniquely you that you guys can make
that we can make eighty seven videos
mapping eighty seven significant groups
based on magnitude of proxies yet that
is not in the best interest of stark on
this just for education of what is how
are you making your decisions as it
efficiency basis usually efficiencies
very hires yeah anything that is less
efficient than it can leave that is not
overly that dramatically important is
but to not fix if you can't okay yeah so
that's number one
yeah I need more power you're gonna sit
in there and you can plug it into your
statement just now it's like I'm never
gonna win that game being like people
don't think you're that nice that's
right
well yeah but nothing is like if I keep
with it right yeah why because people
just are built to be seasonable or
careful too good to be true yes but I
think you're also kind of a hard-ass and
people probably think that you're not
gonna be as nice as you are
you mean depending on where they capture
the context of me it may seem like I've
run very cold they never with you like
one-on-one in the conversation and know
how you like really listen they see you
like a bunch like yelling like [ __ ]
this for everybody there's Gary
Vaynerchuk in this Gary Vee you don't
need me to print out this guy's my dear
just so many marks right you know what
you can do for me
make a list of things that aren't gonna
happen give me a favor
and this is actual real work so like get
into a good zone put on some uber or
whatever you do in the next 20 before
Fri before Saturday morning or well
maybe we do a call Saturday for a quick
minute I need to know what's not gonna
happen and then look at what I'm willing
to like cancel to fit some of that to
happen
[Music]